it is time for hatred, male hatred, male,
one of the favorite times of the week for
many people, one of the worst times of the
week. For others, I guess probably the hatreds
themselves. What is hatred that mail? Here's
a quick reminder.
Brace yourselves for the only information
that can successfully penetrate a 10 foil
hat written by Patriots. Who Hate David Pakman
because America and because freedom.
Okay. This week's hatred, male expressing
shock. How on earth does the David Pakman
show have 650,000 subscribers on Youtube?
Interestingly enough, even since we received
this hatred mail, it's gone up to 660,000
subscribers. Take a look
what? Pacman isn't going to tell you Jews,
they did it. Cut Ends. Dry Socialism. Soros
Media Conglom anti Trump's day in, day out.
Yes. Vladimir. Yes, I do. And Communist. Oh,
BombBomb. Just give me a week. Park man is
controlled opposition propaganda. If you don't
get it, the problem is with you. This is how
they do it. Crafty and secretive. How do people
keep falling for it? How does he have 650
k subscribers?
Yeah. Listen, I, I share the bewilderment
with this hatred, although my bewilderment
maybe comes in a different sense. I'm flattered
by the fact that we now have surpassed 660,000
subscribers on the youtube channel and our
indie top, I dunno what must be 0.5% or so
of Youtube. I think we calculated, I went
back and looked at the numbers again from
the first month that we were on youtube. We
had under a thousand views on youtube the
entire first month. Okay. Understand that
the scale and scope of this. Our first month
on Youtube, we didn't even have a thousand
views for all of our videos combined. We now
are adding a in the neighborhood of four to
500 subscribers a day to youtube, not per
month, a day and closer to 1500 or 2000 today.
Since my appearance on the Joe Rogan program.
So I'm with you, my hatred friend.
I share the astonishment. I think it's a good
thing. You seem to think it's a bad thing.
And uh, I will remind you that the best way
to fight hatred, autism is to sign up for
a membership specifically using the coupon
code hatred at 40. That's h a. T, R. I. O.
T four zero. You save 40% off of your membership.
You get 100% of the member benefits and 3,000
hatreds cry they shed. It's here every single
time that the coupon code
hatred@fortyisusedatwwwdotjoinpacman.com